Biden 2024 is off to a rocky start
Democrats are less than enthusiastic and
the bad headlines are piling up as well
his campaign is said to be quote slow
out of the gates with donors showing a
lack of enthusiasm and close allies are
having to persuade the rich that Joe is
not too old to run and has Vigor yikes
and now we're learning it was Dr Jill's
fault she is apparently the one who
convinced her husband that it was a good
idea to run in helping Joe quote get to
yes on running for reelection at 80. not
a big surprise given that she is his
biggest cheerleader he's not done
he stopped finished what he started look
at all that Joe has
has done has accomplished one of the
Republican candidates is calling for
mental competency tests for those
politicians over the age of 75. what do
you think about that ridiculous look at
what he's doing his energy level his
level of passion
[Laughter]
I would love that costume
come on up Joe
[Laughter]
but Democrats are falling in line and
saying Biden is ready to go Joe Biden is
agile is capable incredibly sharp
incredibly probing incredible command
let's not forget more Americans voted
for this President than any other
president in history people are on fire
uh for the Biden Harris ticket polls
will go up polls will go down but what
won't change are the facts
I don't even know how to start but Dana
I'm going to start with you his energy
level the level of passion the fact is
that Jill Biden is the one who wants
them to run and I think that she
signaled at some Easter egg role uh
before he announced that he's not done
yet he's not the what isn't he done
doing well remember that follows the
State of the Union Address where he kept
saying finish the job yeah and then I
think it's very curious I do not
understand the communications decision
for wanting this story out there so
if you are if you want credit for being
influential you would put it out there I
guess but you're also the one that could
be the one to blame because Biden for
the whole time has been saying I intend
to run but you know like I'll tell you
when I'm ready now we get the story that
she had to convince him to and I'm glad
that she's his biggest cheerleader I
think that anybody who's married should
have that in their relationship that's
great but I also think that there are
some things that the president is going
to have to do himself it is not enough
for people who like him and are friends
with him or who work for him and are in
positions of power because of him to
tell us he's agile and that he's sharp
and that he's on his game Americans have
to see that for themselves we do not see
it remember when he came home from
Ireland and he took the rest of the week
off and part of what he did then is he
recorded that video that announced his
re-election and
since then we've seen him at the White
House Correspondence Dinner yes that was
great but then they always tell these
stories about oh well he only does
events from 10 to for and then they
called a lid last week on one of the
mornings at 9 45 or 10 45 in the morning
you don't even have to do that you can
just say you know the president's busy
and then you can call it at four o'clock
like any normal human being would do
Jesse is it that she's like relishing a
role hanging out at the Super Bowl in
the women's final four she's always in
Dolce and Gabbana uh and you know why
give that up for ju for a dreary life on
the Beach in Delaware I'm with Jill you
do it for the perks you got the chef you
got the jet I don't know she obviously
planted the story because she's had bad
headlines remember she kissed Dougie
fresh on camera she called Hispanics
tacos none of the fashionistas ever say
nice things about her outfit so she was
dying for good press she thinks this is
good press but every wife counsels her
husband that's nothing new
I was on paternity when he announced his
re-election and I didn't even hear about
it it did not break through at all a lot
of other news broke through when I was
away that didn't break through at all
and think about that the guy made no
splash and it's probably because he took
all the drama out of the announcement
remember the last 10 months yeah I'm
probably gonna run I'm just and I
haven't announced it yet okay that's
exciting and then he told Al Roker at an
Easter egg roll he was going to do it so
when he finally did it everybody was
bored permission to make an analogy yeah
Joe Biden is like a nose tackle
he goes in there on short-hearted
situations to plug holes to prevent
Donald Trump from getting into the end
zone that's it he takes up space and
he's there on Fourth and goal and then
he Waddles back out onto the sideline
the guy is not an offensive star he's
not Dynamic he's not going to put points
on the board he's basically a wall
around the White House so Donald Trump
can't jump in he doesn't do anything he
just sits there in blocks that's it and
that's how he's always been I'm not
shocked he can't raise money if you were
a democratic donor would you give money
to Joe now or would you wait until next
year I would wait until next year okay
I'm going to ask you since you're you're
a new mother now a senior Biden advisor
describes Jill as a wife a mom a Nana
who does everything she can to defend
her family what kind of Nana doesn't
recognize her seventh grandchild
then answered no one thinks
thinks that this kid is being sorry
sorry you took the lid off it oh there's
another lid lid at 5 21 here on the five
no one's going to defend that it's just
it's silly at this point it seems like
it would have been an easy win people's
families are weird and strange and you
just say my son had a kid with this
woman and this is my seventh grandkid so
okay but the question really is why not
admit it I know what you think she made
a calculation that it was not going to
be helpful for them or Hunter said no I
don't want this I'm not doing it and
they tiptoe around him they've coddled
him through all of this and just said my
son is perfect my son is perfect instead
of talking about it in real terms that
the average American can understand we
have a son who struggled with addiction
he's overcome this
okay can I can I say something about
politics though since I'm just repeating
myself for that to Jesse's point about
you know he's just a wall keeping Donald
Trump out I obviously think he's done a
lot more than that but it is important
that he is the gatekeeper for that and
there have been a slew of polls that
came out this week from republican
pollsters from Echelon insights from WPA
intelligence people have worked for Ted
Cruz like real conservatives that show
Donald Trump losing to Joe Biden in
every single swing state and on a
national level but Ron DeSantis winning
and there's a chorus of moderate
Republicans even people who were
pro-trump before that are just saying we
will lose if we renominate Donald Trump
and he is the front runner right now by
30 points on average and
Joe Biden being the gatekeeper keeping
Donald Trump out of office when it looks
like he's going to be the candidate is
what Democrats care about most and why
he will have all the money that he needs
and all the support that he needs for
this race Greg how would you wrap this
up well one thing just to uh Jessica Joe
will lose to Trump if inflation doesn't
get under control or we go into a
recession he will lose because you're
going to need somebody with an economic
sense that Joe Biden doesn't like I'm
work shopping a joke though I was
thinking of can I try it out yes why is
Joe Biden like a bad open casket why
because you have to keep calling a lid
see I don't know I'm not sure calling
for a lid I don't know I love the
so-called positive adjectives that are
used to describe Joe like he's capable
it's like something you'd say about
somebody who just had a head injury
Jerry's capable ever since I mean the
head injury it's surprising or you know
he's a he's very agile for a man with no
feet it's something you would say so it
makes you think he's incapable in
bumbling just by mentioning those but I
got to talk about what the most amazing
thing about Dr Jill is how truly amazing
Dr Jill is I mean not a single negative
story ever appearing about her how can
somebody be so perfect right you know
nothing about her judging by the media
she's Joan of Arc to Melania is Lizzie
Borden right and it's totally
predictable because the media always
protects its own and Jill belongs to
them and I don't blame them she is a
doctor which is great for Joe in case of
a medical emergency she can read to him
yeah she's got an education degree I've
got a hundred emails saying why didn't
you say she's not a doctor no she is a
true education doctor yeah ahead the
Biden Administration is sticking it to
blue collar workers everywhere in the
name of their green radical agenda I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now